und wir schauen in die ukraine nach
wochenlangem zögern und zaudern soll nun
also auch der deutsche bundeskanzler
olaf scholz in den kommenden tagen den
weg nach kiew dort wird dann gemeinsam
mit den regierungschefs aus frankreich
und italien auf den ukrainischen
präsidenten lenski treffen und der
bundeskanzler muss ich wohl auf viele
kritische fragen zur haltung der
bundesrepublik in diesem konflikt
einstellen bild vize paul ronzheimer hat
sich jetzt nach knapp acht wochen erneut
mit alexej resta fisch dem top
militärberater zealand kies getroffen
und ihn gefragt was dem deutschen
bundeskanzler in der ukraine erwarten
wird
hier ist das orakel von kiew der top
militär berater von präsident vladimir
selensky bereits mitte april trifft paul
ronzheimer alexia ristovic den mann der
mit seinen analysen und prognosen stets
punktet und schon damals ganz klar sagt
ohne deutsche militärische unterstützung
brot ein monatelanger stellungskrieg
jetzt rund acht wochen später trifft
paul ronzheimer selensky sorat erneut
seine bilanz der letzten entwicklungen
im osten der ukraine ernüchtert
im moment werden unsere truppen von den
russen zurückgedrängt die russen haben
sehr viele schwere waffensysteme die
tief hinter die kampflinien folgen
können sie versuchen unsere soldaten aus
der entfernung zu töten die art der
kriegsführung hat sich einfach geändert
im kampf auf kurze distanz sind wir
relativ gut gerüstet aber derzeit haben
wir große schwierigkeiten seit 60 tagen
haben wir keine möglichkeit adäquat auf
diese art kriegs übrigens zu reagieren
mit tipps der ausweg aus der
dramatischen lage liegt für aristo wird
auf der hand und es ist aus deutscher
sicht erschütternd ja beschämend dass es
sich dabei um dieselbe forderung handelt
wie noch vor wenigen wochen wir brauchen
dringend langstrecken artillerie raketen
dann brauchen wir panzer und gepanzerte
fahrzeuge
unbemannte drohnen und auch ganz
dringend munition für die artillerie
diese wenn sie die waffen von
deutschland von frankreich und den usa
erhalten können und sie dann den krieg
gewinnen ja dann können wir den krieg
gewinnen aber auch nur wenn wir die
benötigten waffen in ausreichender menge
erhalten als der westen uns 120
einheiten langstrecken artillerie- gabe
änderte sich die lage an der front
sofort
von dem besuch der drei regierungschefs
scholz makro und draghi erwartet aristo
wird derweil wenig konstruktives ich
denke sie werden uns versuchen von einem
friedensabkommen zu überzeugen auf
irgendeine art von abkommen auszuhandeln
an welche art von friedensabkommen
denken sie da also das ist jetzt meine
persönliche meinung nicht die meinung
der regierung oder des präsidenten
aber nach meiner einschätzung also ich
befürchte sie wollen uns so was wie die
minsker abkommen außer kraft machen dass
sie werden versuchen uns davon zu
überzeugen dass ein waffenstillstand
schon ein großer erfolg wäre damit
allein der krieg gestoppt werden könnte
dann wird es ihnen darum gehen dass wir
eine humanitäre katastrophe verhindern
müssen das doch putin auch sein gesicht
wahren müsse dass man jetzt einfach
größe zeigen müssen und den russen
vergeben solle damit eine damit seine
zweite chance bis irgendetwas in der art
was erwarten sie also auch von
bundeskanzler scholz
ja das halte ich leider für sehr
wahrscheinlich an den deutschen
bundeskanzler richtet der top berater
von selensky eindringliche worte schon
stolz wir sind mitverantwortlich für
unsere toten soldaten und zivilisten
jeden tag sterben kinder wir verlieren
jeden tag 100 soldaten weil sie uns
keine schweren waffen geben das ist die
ukrainische armee ist stark wir könnten
die russen töten von sie aus unserem
land zurück drängen aber wir brauchen
waffen nieder
und jetzt ist er uns live zugeschaltet
aus kiew paul ronzheimer paul also
sprechen wir direkt über diesen
anstehenden besuch von olaf scholz was
erwartest du von ihm was könnte er
tatsächlich im gepäck haben für die
ukraine
ich glaube nicht dass olaf scholz irgend
etwas im gepäck hat was überraschend
wäre ich glaube nicht dass er seine
rhetorik ändern wird zum beispiel von
einem sieg der ukraine sprechen könnte
und ich glaube auch nicht dass er hier
große versprechungen macht mehr als
symbolik das ist ja eigentlich das was
er verhindern wird und möglicherweise
zeichen beim eu-beitritt eventuell
zumindest hinter verschlossenen türen
dann die debatte um waffen das ist das
ja das maximale glaube ich was passieren
könnte auf der anderen seite glaube ich
auch nicht daran das was der
militärberater also der
präsidentenberater rest ist im interview
gesagt hat dass die drei stunden mit
einem 13 also ein abkommen kommen
könnten ich glaube dafür dass weiß
scholz das weiß man vor ort dafür ist es
momentan viel zu früh das wäre
wahrscheinlich sehr unrealistisch
umsetzbar zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
selbst wenn olaf scholz mehr waffen zu
sicherheit auch schwere waffen wie
kriegsentscheidend wäre das denn
eigentlich für die ukraine könnte die
ukraine mit dem mit der hilfe von
deutschland mit der hilfe von deutschen
waffen auch diesen krieg gewinnen
nur mit der hilfe von deutschen waffen
kann die ukraine diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen das ist ganz klar sie sprechen
auf der einen seite von panzern aber
momentan ist es vor allem ein krieg der
artillerie und da sagt deutschland immer
wieder wir haben zwar ein bisschen
theoretisch was vergeben könnten aber
längst nicht so viel man muss sich alles
vorstellen sandra diese frontlinie dort
im osten die es über 1000 kilometer lang
die russen haben dort eine absolute
mehrheit in der artillerie also man
bräuchte schon von vielen ländern sehr
viel kriegsgerät und dem etwas
entgegenzusetzen
pauler sprechen mir direkt dann über die
lage im donbass was glaubst du wie groß
ist die gefahr dass die russen die jetzt
dort tatsächlich in der übermacht sind
fakten schaffen die dann tatsächlich
nicht mehr umkehrbar sind
die russen schaffen in diesem moment wo
wir sprechen fakten also sollte netz das
ist dieser ort der jetzt bekannt
geworden ist in den vergangenen wochen
ein 10.000 20.000 einwohner großer ort
nicht besonders groß die schlacht hat
dort bereits schon sechs sieben wochen
gedauert also man sieht es ist auch
nicht leicht für die russen
voranzukommen es nicht so dass sie dort
jetzt eine stadt nach der anderen
schnell über rennen würden aber das ist
auch nicht die russische kriegstaktik
momentan die kriegstaktik ist mit
schwerer artillerie
die dörfer die städte zu zerstören und
daten die soldaten rhein zu schicken um
sozusagen auch eigene verluste zu
verhindern 1 lagen die ukraine ganz
bestimmt wenn die russen im donbass
erfolgreich sind also den dort was
komplett erobern lohans die andere
regionen dort im osten erobern dann wäre
das nicht das ende das ist das was die
ukraine hier immer wieder debattiert
wird er mit gesagt moment mal aber wenn
sie das sehr erobern dann werden sie
weiter gehen in die großstädte nach
saporoschje möglicherweise nach metro
nach odessa und dann davon sind wir alle
überzeugt auch in kiew auch vitali
klitschko der bürgermeister dann würden
sie wieder hierher kommen wo ich gerade
stehe lackiert pauli lebt es sich denn
gerade in kiew du bisher seit ein paar
tagen auch wieder vor ort mit diesem
gedanken dass es eventuell auch dort
wieder angriffe geben könnte ich meine
die menschen kern ja auch langsam wieder
in ihre heimat auch in die hauptstadt
zurück
absolut richtig da die menschen kern
zurück das habe ich hier auch erlebt als
ich vom polen mit der bahn hierüber bin
frauen kinder mit taschen und emotional
sie haben fast geweint hat sich wieder
angekommen sind er nimmt stadt in der
stadt selbst entwirft zumindest im
zentrum da erinnert nicht so viel
momentan an den kriegt muss man sagen es
gibt nicht mehr diese check points und
man kontrolliert wird diese nervosität
natürlich in den ersten wochen monaten
davon nichts zu spüren die restaurants
wieder geöffnet geschäfte geöffnet nur
die curve you also die ausgangssperre
und hin und wieder die sie reden sie
erinnern daran an diesen krieg und die
menschen ist mein eindruck bei diesen
sommerlichen temperaturen
versuchen das so ein bisschen zu
verdrängen also dass sie auch wieder
hier in gefahr sein können sie wollen
jetzt daran glauben dass kiew zumindest
sicher ist aber das ist natürlich ein
trugschluss wir sehen aber natürlich
nicht zu verdenken paul dankeschön für
den moment nach kiel